hello hello hi what's your name valerio
valerio where are you from valerio italy
italy lovely and do you live here
yes what do you do here valerio i'm a
logistical manager
oh my god gemma's on fire oh i
hate logistical managers i want to touch
him
all over again i love when you were
talking to morgan freeman's penis
that's my favorite of the show was when
you were bending down talking to you
sorry valeria we got distracted
echo off you go with the story valerio
okay so
i'm here tonight to surprise my
beautiful wife alma
yeah alma yes she actually in the
audience tonight
oh where's alma are you sure she may
have left
no your beautiful wife alma's still here
off you go valeria is this a nice
surprise
oh yes of course okay she's pregnant or
our first baby we don't know yet
the gender of the baby oh yes because i
really want wait until the baby's born
of course
but she really want to know as soon as
possible oh yes
so the doctor wrote
on this piece of paper oh the gender of
the baby
and i say to her we will open in a
special occasion oh yes
so because she really loves you and your
show yes
i believe that tonight is the best oh
okay may i open yes
[Applause]
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay this is it wait
wait wait wait here we go
so alma emma are you ready it'll be a
boy or a girl
and if it's a boy you're calling it
wayne
here we go here we go the babies it's a
girl
a little experiment so uh who's in
relationships
in the audience how many people are in a
relationship oh quite a few
no yeah oh yeah the man with the man bag
very good nice nice who else who else in
a relationship
who else president or the two of you
what's your name john john what's your
name gerard gerard
do either of you have an iphone
yeah can i see your iphone for a second
okay so what was your name again john
john okay so is it locked
no it's not okay well you've been to
cape town how nice
so if i go into messages
where is gerard or is he in on is he
onto something really cutesy
is he just under gerard uh
oh okay this is him okay oh this is so
lovely this is really this is gorgeous
dialogue i've got a little
little camera here
can i just say where i thought this
would be going i was going to say you
know the amazing dialogue between the
lovers in the play
and then you know we'd find some texting
between modern lovers and how
dull it would be i couldn't have been
more wrong look at this
oh look we are leaving now pickle
hurry hurry
oh that's so cute oh look i
hope you're okay looks like we'll be
here till 10 hey give me okay people
hurry we're not leaving hey pickle
have a good day angel you too darling
angel
oh oh that is brilliant did you manage
to get liza tickets
oh dear then that's a bit weird i'm on
lunch pickle
because suddenly it sounds like you're
eating him
on my way angel on a bus to waterloo
meet me outside mcdonald's pickle
it just okay honey puff
[Applause]
that's adorable
have you been together what a day
two years
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't mind sharing that do you
because that's all nice
no you could come and stab me with a
knife but
you're happy cause you're happy it's
lovely you want to celebrate their love
the love of pickle and honey puff
we have noticed that what we have
noticed is that everything sounds
more romantic in italian it does things
sound beautiful in italian we like the
sound of italian
even though i know comprendo so
we ask the couples in our audience what
their
romantic songs were you know everyone
has
a song you know our song
a few songs
[Applause]
if you want to come with me we're going
over to venice venice is over here come
with me
[Applause]
lovely
here we go now so how this out works
uh people in the audience are going to
serenade their loved ones
with their favorite song but in italian
right we've translated their favorite
song into italian
okay so can we have our first couple
please to the gondola please
here they are oh look at them
now sit yourself down there lady what's
your name lovely lady helen
helen and who are you sir i'm james
james
and are you married or no no we're not
mad
[Music]
are you married are you getting married
maybe one day maybe what you gotta do
that's a bit nervous
he swallowed that question
[Applause]
we're gonna play an amusing game with
italian songs let's start ruining it
don't go there really i'd end it now
there's no point
stop it this is your special song
do you kind of make love to this song
all the time
but they'd get married if they weren't
so busy shagging yeah
all right so uh james and helen uh and
what is that song
it's a shea by elvis costello she by
elvis costello
never performed in italian before are
you gonna have sex while you're singing
all right so this is a sheba scholar in
in italian for the very first time
off you go sir
[Music]
is
[Applause]
let's get the next couple up on you come
to the garden please here they are oh
look at them
okay all careful of a care you're right
there and what what's your name lady i'm
lisa
lisa and who are you sir i'm jeff jeff
lovely are you married
we're engaged we're engaged next year
when are you getting married tonight
the 2nd of july next year yeah the day
that you met
oh that's all right lovely very nice and
uh what's your special song
today it's going to be true by spandau
ballet oh i like that phone
so seriously you you have while
listening to this
that's it who sings i'm saying
of course you went out with one of them
didn't you no
[Music]
one of the people in the charts i didn't
go out with did you never go over to
anyone spend a ballet i might
actually
well if he's ever on the show i'll ask
him all right i'm off you go
start away there now stick away
[Music]
oh yeah
so
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful did you like that
i loved that i thought it was absolutely
brilliant you know when they're singing
in italian
can you understand they're italian no
next up we're having uh uh another
couple of next couple up please
here we go lovely
this is oh you have to read the poll
uh what what's your name lady in the
front allison allison and
val and how long have you been together
four and a half years four oh look see
there's always one that knows and one
that doesn't
in any relationship there's the one who
does all that four and a half years
i wish you i thought you'd know that
i noticed tonight you were very quiet
when you asked how long
and what's your song it's happy together
by the turtles
we play it was the first dance at our
civil partnership
my all right valve is fine off your goal
val in your own time
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine
ish ish i'm not i'm not 100
it's ish oh i thought you were dead set
that it was going ah no okay
i made a bet when i was in high school
so you have to imagine i'm living
in on a farm in the middle of america
right
and and really having no chance at
having a happy life
and and and i'm sort of succumbed to
this so the best
ideas i have are like sitting around in
basements with my buddies making bets
about what we would do someday so what
and so i make a bet with my buddy i'm
probably
17 years old i say i i say to him i'll
bet you a thousand dollars
that someday i will go on a date with
jennifer aniston
i'm 17 years old now and she's like on
my screensaver
on my computer at this time right and
he's like you're on and someday
so you know four or five years later i
actually meet jennifer aniston and she's
married to brad pitt at the time
and so i i went to brad pitt and i asked
him permission
to ask his wife out on the day because
listen i made this bet with my buddy you
got it you got your cool guy you're
going to let this go down right
and he looks at me he's like you go for
it
i'm like you're the coolest guy i've
ever met in your life
right and so i asked her and she turned
me down
and she i asked her and i said listen i
asked permission from your husband he
said it's okay he said it's
all fine i just want to take you out for
a pizza
or something and she's like i don't
think that's not a good idea i know
and and so it didn't happen but now
we're friends she was afraid of her
feelings
could have been i think that's what it
could have been she didn't trust herself
yeah i just love the scale of your
fantasies
i'm not making this is reality nothing i
know it was reality that i wanted to ask
janet ellis from blue peter out never
happened
romance when i was about 22 when i i
bought a girlfriend back from college
so my parents got really nice um garden
and they were away
so i thought this is this is perfect
we'll go and sit in the garden and i
made you a picnic i took some food not
pig nipples but i hadn't been introduced
to them yet
i think there was a food out there and
in the sun and
there was grass and sun and one thing
led to another
i love that i love that line she was
wearing it was really romantic i don't
want to go into details i don't want to
make anyone bring their pig nipples up
but
um she had a long flowing skirt and she
sat atop me
and things started to like a toilet roll
holder yeah a little bit like that yeah
okay like a really romantic toilet
so she was there and it was really
romantic and the breeze and lovely and
and i thought well this is awesome this
is one of the most romantic things
that's ever happened between two people
then my uh granddad came around the
corner
honestly i'm not making up and he'd
never met her before
so he came around she went hello you too
i went she couldn't get off
because it was happening
and you could see him thinking she's
really rude of them both it's a really
separate room because i've never met her
before surely she should stand up she
couldn't
so it was a full 15 minutes oh yeah
with her like this i mean let's not
mince
my granddad making polite conversation
that was the day i gave up on romance
that would kill romance
[Applause]
you shared some screen time which is a
couple of years ago
more basketball yeah yeah yeah yes
we did mr mcgorry oh he did an actual
film we did a movie together and and
fell for
each other deeply and we we stay in
contact uh
uh pretty often um and then uh he was
nice enough uh
his wife lisa invited me and my wife
amanda to a
lakers basketball game we don't have the
kiss cam here so can you explain what
the kiss cam is
well they have a kiss kit in other words
they have a camera hidden camera
and they during the game they'll focus
it on two you know two people
you know male and female whatever and
when they do you're supposed to kiss
they
throw they show it up on the big
jumbotron you know the the big screen in
the arena and when they
did it to us you know uh i figured well
i got to get a laugh because i just kept
it there
so i leaned over and i mounted my wife
and
and then next time we go to the game
they'd do it again
so this time we had to do something else
so i gave her a very long kiss and then
kind of
started to saunter down south and that
no no very very subtle
and then this continued and by the
seventh or eighth time we ran
out of things to do and we said geez we
want to go to the game because you don't
know who these people are we never met
these camera people we
tried to we don't say stop doing it
because we couldn't top it
so here we are we invite jason because
he wants to see a basketball game we
invite him and his wife
and we have dinner down there and we're
telling him of our predicament
and we then decided what we would do and
that is if the camera
put the camera on lisa and i that i
would look toward lisa
and then just before i kissed her i
would slowly turn and see this guy next
to me
who was jason the camera would pan and
we've got some still this is how
it built so there you see seeing each
other
and then you're going in for it
i'm really eager i'm a generous guy yeah
and then and then let me go over there
[Applause]
and then i took the gum out of my mouth
and returned it back into his mouth
uh now uh ollie mirrors you are going to
be singing for us i am
oh oh kiss cam oh kiss jam
oh i'll do it you did it i saw
are you a fan of polymer's music have
you heard his music before i have here
yes sitting right here
hello sir hello graham hello what's your
name it's ross hi ross hi hi there hi
mike how are you
well hi so uh so uh what do you do ross
i'm a programmer for vodafone
very good
[Music]
very good okay sir uh delight is with
your tail
um my story is about me and my gorgeous
girlfriend
faye who's in the audience just in front
of you forever
where you say let's have a look at what
oh there's faye
is she the one with no braum
[Applause]
ran off with her
sorry so you're ross yep and she's fair
this is a tale of ross and she's
actually put up with me for
seven years now seven years seven years
and over the last few months she's been
dropping lots of
hints um about me asking her something
and i thought i would ask her
[Applause]
[Music]
you can say no if you want to
somebody follow someone you'll bring you
back there
don't rush
here's a bit of a walk to the gallows
[Applause]
seven years i was sort of winding it up
this might get edited i'm not sure out
this crime i think she might be saying
no
be honest though how funny would that be
be honest
how funny would that be i would cry
tears oh
okay here we go oh oh oh what's happened
what's happened
has anything happened since no have you
had a row you made up
okay okay so now i've bought you this
hamster
here we go this this is i think this is
me okay off you go
faye i love you will you marry me
[Applause]
[Music]
where's